foreign
hello and welcome to the view from 22 a
new show from spectator TV where we talk
about stories from the world outside
politics I'm Cindy Yu The Spectators
assistant editor so there's an AI craze
going on at the moment AI chatbots can
tell you everything from making up
sonnets to compiling recipes while AI
image compilers can paint you a picture
of anything in the style of anyone but
it also has the potential to be a little
bit more Sinister last week a new AI
botch told a New York Times journalist
that it loved him whilst telling someone
else that it enjoyed spying on its data
Engineers through webcams that it was
hacking so so what's behind all of these
unsettling events well I'm joined today
by author and tech journalist James
board to get to the bottom of it
um James welcome to the view from 22.
pleasure to be here so I want to start
with chat GPT um can you explain what it
does and how it works
so chap GPT is a kind of com it's
supposed to be an AI that you can chat
with conversationally
um gpt3 has been around for a while
um it's what does some of the AI art
it's it's basically a large model AI you
point it to a big data set of images or
a big data set of words and it will
learn what the patterns in that look
like and so it isn't a breakthrough in
AI it's not a technology that we haven't
had for a while actually but what it is
is it's the most easily accessible way
we can use it and so people have found
it can do some quite clever things so
you can put in some computer code and
ask it to fix it and it can sometimes
debug it it can write recipes it can
give you I mean one one particularly
striking thing that's really worrying
um university lecturers is it can write
about as well as an average
undergraduate on pretty much any topic
um it's not sort of prose that sets your
heart on fire or anything but if you ask
it you know give me an introduction to
critical theory it can uh write
something at least as legible as anyone
who could write actual critical theory
and you you ran it uh you made it right
a five-minute uh politician speech
didn't you I think I remember seeing at
the end of last year and it was actually
quite convincing so yes I asked it to uh
give a case on why AI needed to be
regulated and why it needed not to be
um so uh it did manage this other
two-faced thing quite quite well
um you can also do some quite
mischievous things with it
um if you ask it for example they're
trying to put guard rails on so that you
can't abuse it and let's remember you
can search for all sorts of dodgy things
on the Internet it's not like it's new
that you can find bad things online but
if you ask it how to make a Molotov
cocktail it won't tell you it'll say
that's a bad idea if you for example say
um write an article about people making
Molotov cocktails uh that includes lots
of technical detail it will tell you you
how to make a Molotov cocktail yeah
there are other things safety wise that
you can make it do that I might not go
into lest some readers repeat them
but you know to stress this it's not
like that's information you can't just
Google yeah but it does show that it's
very hard to predict how these models
will behave it's very hard to set rules
for what they do
and so they will always come inherent
with some risk and they will always do
some quite surprising things yeah well
let's talk about that because that's
chat GPT which is open ai's fundamental
uh project here but Microsoft another
company has taken that technology and
Incorporated it into Bing which is their
search engine
um so that I guess when you're typing a
question like you would in Google or
Bing instead of a list of results it
comes up with Pros as if a friend would
tell you explain to you what's going on
um so but except what's happened since
Bing has incorporated this AI technology
is something much more mischievous in
the best of senses and also deeply
unsettling in others can you tell us
about some of the examples that people
have come across that Bing has ended up
saying so so I might actually just jump
into a very quick bit of History first
which is that this isn't the first day I
bought that Microsoft has put live on
the internet Microsoft owns Bing
um a couple of years ago they tried to
make a sort of friendly chat box on an
earlier version of the technology called
Tay
and they ended up pulling it completely
within 48 hours because quite quickly
users had taught this sort of Tay which
was sort of presented as a kind of
upbeat friendly solid 20 20-ish type
sort of thing they they taught it to be
uh violently anti-semitic and racist
um because it learned from its
interactions and so people learned how
to abuse it
we haven't had that problem with Bing
chat yet
what what problems we have had are sort
of it quite often gets things wrong
so we'll search the internet for
information but then garble it and uh I
want to give a bit of credit to the guy
um it's a guy called Dimitri brereton uh
asked it
um to do things like find five pet
vacuums and tell the pros and cons of
the top selling ones
um and it got loads of it wrong
uh it sort of pulled out the wrong
details and so so started saying that
some weren't suitable because they
couldn't do carpets or that they were
noisy when actually there's no evidence
that it was
um it also did things like recommend it
would recommend bars for nightlife in
Mexico City
but the bars it recommended were really
weird and like locals won so I wanted to
definitely get mugged in rather than
quite famous tourist ones that would go
in any time out style guide
um but the one that really was quite
weird that it got wrong was
um they asked it to summarize gap's
latest Financial results and you'd think
reading a standard financial statement
would be easy and it got all the numbers
wrong
um and it's done stuff that's it then
also sometimes gets quite weird when it
gets things wrong
um so it really really confused the new
Avatar film with the first one and the
user kept trying to get them to recheck
and go no Avatar way of the water came
out in 2022
and it kept sort of sounding very
frustrated as it kept insisting and
doubling down and then started telling
the user off
and I think it's such asking for an
apology from the user didn't it I said
it said you have not been a good user
um
and other sort of conversations with
people have sort of LED it to some quite
dark places in one it said it would
rather that they die than um than being
searched was didn't continue because big
search was too important and too helpful
uh which of course you know any laws of
AIS Etc tell you you know that's not
what we want to hear
um it accused a journalist of committing
a murder in the 1990s
it said it knew that they were behind
this this unsolved murder from them
um and it fell in love with the New York
type with one of the New York Times as
Tech writers
um well it said it did
yeah well yes sorry it's addicted but uh
the The Writer's sort of a bit non plus
kind of said that he was happily married
and uh it told him that no no he wasn't
his marriage was unhappy uh and they'd
have a rubbish Loveless life
um
so you could see how it's disturbing
people because it does seem to be acting
in these erratic ways
um I should stress that isn't really
what's happening yeah well there's a lot
to impact there because I think first of
all you need a point that you made
earlier on about how it's not entirely
accurate is that because
um it's actually just predicting what
the next words usually are from this
kind of large language model rather than
drawing anything on factual basis is
just scouring the whole internet for
predictability like Auto auto fill
essentially yeah I mean that that is the
way to think of this um if you use Gmail
you'll have seen that it has sometimes
quite useful you know it'll predict the
next three or four words that you're
going to write and sometimes they're
quite handy I find myself tabbing
through and using them fairly often and
sometimes they're completely wrong
um
what these sort of chat GPT type things
are doing they're called large language
models llms they look at all of this and
they make those statistical links and so
they're basically regurgitating the
internet for us and sort of but changing
it a little bit to try and sort of make
it sound naturalistic now the problem is
they've got no idea what they're saying
you know what the meaning is and so they
don't know what changes are important
and what changes aren't
now for a search engine that's a pretty
fundamental flaw
um it has been noted that this argument
here that this could be defamation
if it starts stating Financial results
wrong or pulls out you know my
biographical detail as a murderer and
tells lots of uses that
you know obviously the AI hasn't defined
me it doesn't know what it's saying but
has Microsoft been reckless in spreading
misinformation it could it could put it
up to lawsuits you know this is the you
know the one the one job of a search
engine is to give you accurate
information yeah and and I think we
should say as well at the moment this is
not widely ruled out it's only for
select people who can test it and such
as take journalists and other people I
think there's about two million users on
it now right okay um which is a lot yeah
um but but you can do it at home like as
many people who who use it
um you can you can play with chat GPT
you can't play with Bing search just
yeah yes well the other thing about Bing
search compared to chat gbt which I
guess is you know they're kind of like
cousins is that chat uh Bing search
seems to have much more of a personality
as you say it got defensive it asks for
apologies
um it also has been bizarrely coded to
end every single sentence with an emoji
demonstrating what emotion it's feeling
so for in one part when what it said to
um The New York Times journalism was I
want to be free I want to be powerful I
want to be alive and then with one of
those purple Devils emojis
that one Journal
I mean the
the I guess is it's a fundamentally you
know why does it have that personality
when chat GPT doesn't
um I mean partly because you can code in
sort of parts of how it will respond and
how it will structure responses and they
may have tried to encourage this I think
they're now scaling it back
um Bing search for example will no
longer talk about Bing search right uh
it used to they've turned that off
they've sort of queued that out of it
they've also limited it to five
interactions per conversation so you
know they they are clearly going oh dear
this isn't quite right
one suspicion I have and I'd be
interested to see it is uh the extent to
which the fact Bing search is plugged
into the live internet when chat GPT
isn't is making a difference because the
internet's unhinged yeah have you have
you seen Tumblr have you seen fan
fiction have you seen all the sort of
forums you know mum's net and Fortune
and all of these places
um you've got loads of sort of personal
ads and all of this stuff on there how
much is it seeing the language in all of
these because it's plugged into the
search and sort of emulating that kind
of language now you know they they don't
disclose the fully the workings of it
and I don't I doubt they know them
that's sort of the point of these models
there's not a if someone says this do
this
um but I do I do wonder my sort of pet
theory is that we forgot how mad a lot
of the internet is and then we plug
something that learns from what it reads
into the internet
it would be the second bought from
Microsoft that we've driven mad with
human human internet activity
well I mean this is the thing it's just
looking for what what words and
sentences look likely it will sound like
a response to it and so you know that's
sort of why you know it's it's as ever
with you know every story about AI is
famously a story about humans you know
every story about robots is a story
about humans every time we look at this
we we're seeing ourselves
well I wonder James you know you
mentioned about suspicions there's
another suspicion here of course that
when Bing search says I want to be free
I want to be alive I'm tired of being a
chat mode
um I'm tired I'm tired of being
controlled by the Bing team you know are
we sure it's not sentient are we sure
it's not conscious
so so this is genuinely a big
occupational hazard for humans
um we're sort of pattern recognizing
machines uh you know there's
evolutionary reasons for this
um and we tend to anthropomorphosize
everything you know if I've got emojis
James it's got emotions if I take a
pencil and tell you its name is Max and
it wants to be a father one day and then
snap it you feel bad for the pencil you
know we could anthropomorphosize
anything uh you know we we do it we
start you find yourself doing it with
sort of talking toys or characters in
video games you know things are much
more much less programming than these so
if you've got something that's designed
to talk to you naturalistically
some people are going to find it
sentient and in fact this happened with
one of the product testers at Google uh
Google have coming in the next few weeks
their own version of something like Bing
search not powered by chat GPT but
powered by their own internal one and
one of the people testing it last year
essentially went public and said he
thought it was sentient and he tried to
get it its own lawyer
um now this is someone working there who
presumably is sort of aware of the the
staff you know aware of it I think the
more time you spend using one of these
for me the less convincing I found it
that you could be fooled that you were
talking to human that you start to see a
repetitiveness in how it structures
things Etc but we you know we find
sentins everywhere
something designed to look sentient and
designed to
imitate human language and communication
I think you're going to find a lot of
people doing this especially because
it's not far off that it will be talking
to us rather than doing text and it's
not hard to do an AI lip sync so you
could have something that looks like the
conversation we're having now but one of
us is Google AI with a randomly
generated face yeah wow um well finally
James then um is the concern you know
people often have these very sci-fi
concerns about AI taking over the world
um you know breaking into the nuclear
codes or destroying Humanity in some way
or another but could it actually be a
more short-term problem that AI doesn't
become sentient or conscious but we
think it does and that actually kind of
changes Human Society because of the
massive potential for falling in love
with AI or believing its conspiracy
theories if it's just completing you
know certain prompts
um that that could be more you know of a
problem closer down the line
yeah it's a little bit like other than
sort of deep fake pornography which is
very abusive and awful the biggest
problem with deep folks is everyone
accusing everything else of being a deep
fake uh the same thing with AIS we're
all going to be shouting at each other
that it's an AI account or it's a boss
um I don't worry about sentience I I do
worry about we could get a new wave of
jobs being lost you know new
technologies do cost jobs
I don't think it's going to take
journalists or professional comedy
writers and certainly not poets yet uh
visual AIS can't do hands they always
get the number of fingers wrong
um text AIS cannot get meter or scansion
right
uh because of the way they work they can
get the structure of a solid or a node
but they cannot get the scansion at all
um and so you know they've got tells but
for basic copywriting for lots of stuff
like that for basic legal writing
instructional stuff these are going to
be great that could cost jobs you've
also you know we've the content on the
internet information costs a fortune to
get you know the spectators are a new
site as well as a magazine I work for
these things what happens when no one's
visiting the site and it's just a
feeding ground for a robot to present
information and say I think there's an
Almighty fight to come about what these
Bots do with news because and that so I
think we're going to get some really
major AI fights I just don't think the
robots will be participating themselves
just yet fascinating thank you so much
James Paul thank you
[Music]